news now is your local election
headquarters you can find updates on the
presidential race on air and online
eight newsnow dot com alex all right a
lot more still ahead on this wednesday
if you plan a vote on election day it
will be busy at the polls
we'll talk to sheriff joe lombardo about
how metro will keep people safe
as they cast their ballots we have
morning cup of joe coming up along with
a check of news and traffic
sponsored by the pact coalition
we've been following breaking news all
morning on several parts of the valley
but we're going to go here to flamingo
and 95 or near there anyway
a murder suicide being investigated by
metro police hector mejia is live
there right now with the latest details
hector good morning
good morning john and detectives tell us
this all started as an argument between
a man
and a woman and it ended with murder and
it happened inside
one of the homes you see here down this
block there you see a police cruiser in
the middle of the street and they tell
us
it was the quick thinking of a roommate
that might have saved
more lives officers say they were called
out to a domestic disturbance call
just before one o'clock this morning and
they say a roommate woke up to an
argument between
a roommate and the husband she went into
their room
when she noticed the man had a gun she
immediately grabbed the child
took him outside and called 9-1-1 when
officers were finally able to get inside
the home
they found the man dead from an apparent
self-inflicted gunshot wound
and the woman was also shot but died
when she got to the hospital
and because this happened as officers
moved in they tell us
that the investigation will take a
little more time as they sort out the
details and we expect them to
release body camera footage within the
next 72 hours
reporting live from flamingo on the 95.
hector mejia
8 news now